من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام اذا
اسماعيل يتحدث عن وضع كارثي بكل المقاييس
حيث يتواجد ماذا عن المشهد
لديك المشهد في رفح ربما مشابه الى حد
كبير لكنه ربما يكون مختلف ف المعبر رفح
ربما يشكل نافذه لايصال المساعدات الى
مدينه رفح لكنها لا تصل عند اسماعيل في
غزه او حتى في شمال القطاع ووصل بهم الامر
في غزه وشمال القطاع الى اكل اعلاف
الحيوانات طحنها وتحويلها الى دقيق ربما
حتى في مدينه غزه هناك مساعدات تصل ان
كانت شحيحه وقليله للغايه لكنها اخر نقطه
تصل اليها هي عند الشوارع اساسيه شارع
الرشيد او شارع صلاح الدين عند دوار
الكويت او حتى عند شارع الرشيد في مدينه
غزه لكنها لا تستطيع الوصول الى شمال
القطاع وبالتالي هناك مجاعه في شمال
القطاع اكبر منها في مدينه غزه اكبر منها
في مناطق مختلفه بالتالي في مدينه رفح
الاوضاع تزداد خطوره وكارثه مع الارتفاع
في عداد النازحين مدينه خانيونس تتعرض الى
قصف عنيف الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يركز
عملياته في مدينه خانيونس خاصه في المناطق
الغربيه هو يحاصر مدينه خانيونس لليوم
الثامن على التوالي وبالاخص مستشفى ومجمع
ناصر الطبي وكذلك مستشفى الامل التابع
للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني يطلق النار ويطلق
القذائف ما زال اطلاق النار والقذائف هما
سيدال موقف في مدينه خانيونس بينما ايض
يشن غارات على مناطق مختلفه كما حدث في
منطقه الزوايده وكما حدث في النصيرات ع
شقق عده ومنازل مختلفه شنت عليها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه غارات عنيفه دمرتها
وسوتها بالارض وكان هناك اعداد من الشهداء
والجرحى من بينهم اطفال لكن الاوضاع تزداد
خطوره في رفح لان اعداد النازحين باتت
كبيره لا لا تتحمل هذه المدينه الصغيره كل
هذا العدد الكبير ويعيشون اوضاعا صعبه
وكارثه في ظل احوال جويه سيئه نحن نتحدث
عن اليوم الثالث اليوم من المنخفض الجوي
وكانت الليله الماضيه ماطره وقبلها وقبلها
وبالتالي هناك غرق لعشرات بل مئات من
الخيام من جراء هذه الامطار هناك اقتلاع
واقتلعت عدد من الخيام من جراء الرياح
الشديده بينما لا يتوفر ادنى مقومات
الحياه في رفح حتى رغم ان معبر رفح متواجد
في رفح الا ان مقاومات الحياه لا تتوفر
بسبب شح هذه الامكانات وشح ايضا المساعدات
التي تص الدقيق المقومات المعلبات
والاغذيه والاهم من كل ذلك الماوى السكان
ياتون الى مدينه رفح من خان يونس ولا
يجدون ماوى لان الجيش الاسرائيلي يجرده من
امتعتهم ومن فراشهم ومن اغطيتي ابون الى
رفح الى المجهول لان الان مدينه رفح فيها
خيام في الشوارع في على ناصيه الشوارع على
الارصفه في كل الاراضي الزراعيه نصبت خيام
لكنها لا تكفي لكل هذا العدد الكبير نحن
نتح
عن نصف سكان قطاع غزه متواجدين في هذه
المدينه الصغيره فكيف لهؤلاء ان يسكنوا
كيف لهؤلاء ان ي ان توفر لهم البلديات
المياه والغذاء وكل ما يلزمهم من مقومات
الحياه وبالتالي في ظل هذه الاوضاع وهذا
المنخفض الجوي الصعب والشديد على قطاع غزه
بالتاكيد ستكون حياتهم كارثيه شكرا لك
هشام زقوت مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من رفح
جنوب قطاع غزه